m
des membres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
oh
bernard adamus est votre première
entrevue en près de deux ans parce qu'il
ya un long silence radio depuis votre
message mis en ligne sur facebook vous
avez écrit je vous cite bob il est temps
que tu te ferme la trappe pour un tapis
vite à part de tout ça c'est que mon
message facebook était un peu tragique
de cange des rues
c'est comme mon album en fait quand je
les rues à la fin j'étais comptable
ouais t'as pas trop y penser deux fois
fait que j'ai écrit ça de même sa sortie
comme ça
le temps était peut-être un peu plus
intense que qu'est ce que je ressentais
moi même mais bon je l'écris comme s'il
y avait du vrai là dedans on avait juste
wathelet mon cas j'ai eu un flash jetant
gaspésie en voyage je me lassais dans
l'espèce de pornic gianni nicchi était
en trio qui avait déjà quelques
nouvelles thoune qui sont sur le disque
à ce moment sa mort comme un peu rappelé
le feeling que j'ai eu quand andrew pyle
numéro deux mondial du fait que tout
soit mis en scène avec la grosse fatigue
turn of the soul of si rappelons-le fait
que c'est un besoin est arrivé pendant
que vous avez tiré la plogue vous êtes
parti cinq lois aux états unis que
c'était pour vous une source
d'inspiration ce voyage c'est ce qui a
été source de plein d'affaires sauf
grande belle grande source de décrochage
c'était vraiment le fun ii juste partout
au québec at large surtout montréal mais
juste de plus voire pas que je les aie
hyjal avec qui je pense tout bas je pose
avait juste besoin de ne pas voir la
face à personne puis pour voir la mienne
et pendant cette période de réflexion
vous n'avez pas toucher à votre guitare
pendant des mois au respect que ma
curiosité pourquoi je te parie le juste
du temps réfléchir à faire une toune
façon de parler
il y avait comme vraiment ça s'il y
avait comme pour que c'est une
obligation mais d'expo niang et puis
j'ai encore ce réflexe la hauteur peu
importe même quand je bosse sur 2 ha
quand j'essaie de toujours façon de
parler dans ma tête passait à penser à
une phrase puis passé que ce soit un
refrain ou peu importe mais il ya
toujours ce qui fonctionne dans ma tête
c'était mathieu personne mais je pense
tout le temps si quoi que je veux dire
là dessus je tu as juste années de
penser à tout le temps que je vous avais
vendu soit s'appelle copie de votre
premier disque à 40000 du deuxième way
26 mai 3e exactement ça me met beaucoup
de pression pour 80 on a avant le repos
n'est pas vraiment en dessous on n'est
plus du tout à la même époque
non la pression c'est juste je pas
pourquoi le g20 de la pression par
rapport à la réponse de ce disque lot et
le monde vont tu être là ils vont
trouver ça trop 500 est trop simple trop
je sais pas quoi ça faisait juste
longtemps j'avais pas fait d un album
simplement fait que ça vaut mieux je te
jure sur ma pression a fait genre de
voir comment vont réagir
vous vous apprêtez à donner 40 concerts
d'ici la fin d'année 2010 un ouais
qu'allez vous faire pour ne pas répéter
ce que vous avez vécu les années
précédentes pour ne pas brûler la
chandelle par les deux groupes de petits
détails de pas nécessairement dormir
aussi conserve à jouer parce que l'hôte
et le petit fois avec l'ego du band tout
le temps le forme de tennis man met en
question on peut venir fois réussi à
montréal puisse réveiller que nos
blondes qui ceux qui ont du temps afin
que les enfants d'hétéros jeu pour eux
de voir le comment
face aux similaires sont investis de la
tournée l'on se le cachera pas là mais
juste faire attention en coupe de détail
de poids nécessaire mais à toutes les
fois spectacle face après le show qui je
sais des gardes s'est vraiment rendu
entre guillemets était vif lé présent un
peu soin puis rentre chez ou qu'il y
aura un demain puis ça va être correct
[Musique]
ati faire la fête c'est tout un drôle
tout temps le feuilleton steve r je
pense est un bon bout de temps
100% agent c'est le cas tu vois le monde
descend bossage francs mais tu vois le
monde faire de paris un bel effet tandis
que les gones ne sait pas vraiment si
drôle que sorte
pis aucun qui constamment cette partie
si jamais grave on verra lorsque je
parle beaucoup mais je lis pas fait
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]